Now, the answer is no. Within the population of everyone who took the BBC test,
you guys are a sample. There are a lot of different samples we could take of all
the people that took the test. We can take big samples, and small samples. And,
while your sample could get the same averages as those from the entire
population. There will also be samples that don't have the same averages. The
average memory score of the population is called the population parameter and
it's denoted by mu. It's a funny little Greek symbol. And the average for the
sample is called a sample statistic and we generally denote it by x bar. An x
with a bar on top. Now, I want to stress, please don't be nervous about symbols.
I know a lot of people get pretty nervous when they see symbols that they
haven't seen before. But in mathematics, we really need symbols to illustrate
our points. Think of it like, when you're playing a musical instrument, and you
have sheep Sheet music.
How else are we going to make sure that people in future generations learn these
classical melodies? Sheet music is the best way to do that. And same with, in
mathematics when we use symbols. We need to be able to articulate are thoughts
to other people all around the world. And that's one things that's really cool
about mathematics it's a universal language. So don't worry, you'll soon become
familiar with these symbols because we're going to use them throughout this
course. Now we can use this sample statistic to approximate the population
parameter. But generally, they won't be exactly the same. The difference between
these two is called the sampling error. Which means we can make educates guesses
about population parameters using sample statistics, but we probably won't be
100% accurate. That's why it's really important to have a good sample that can
better predict the population parameter. So going back the quiz, no. We don't
think that the average scores for this class will be exactly the same. But it
will probably come close, and we're going to be able to see that later.